and it's going round and round and round
and
i don't know how many takes we were able
to do before i completely
freaked out maybe three and i was like
okay i'm done i have to get out of this
i can't do
it anymore we got it in take one though
the other two takes were just for me to
torture her
[Music]
[Applause]
hi i'm neil yovovich and i'm paul
anderson
and we will be breaking down the diablo
scene from our new movie monster hunter
[Music]
is about halfway through the film mila
has been stranded on this
island of rock surrounded by an ocean of
sand
and inside the sand lives the diablos
that can pop out at any moment when
there's any kind of vibration on the
sand
uh so it's kind of like uh mila and tony
jard trapped on a desert island with a
shark
circling them and they've got to figure
out a way to get off the island
and defeat this giant monster the
diablos and
they think they have a plan but we'll
see whether it works or not
and by the way at this point mila's
already fought the diablos once and it
didn't go terrible
terribly well at all
well you know our approach on the movie
was that um
obviously we had to build the creatures
in cg everything else should be as real
as it could possibly be
so for a scene like this where you know
gravity is
is is doing what gravity does you know i
i didn't want to fake it
you know i didn't want mila kind of just
in the in the vehicle and then us
having cg objects drift around her i
wanted to actually put her in a real
vehicle and then twist the vehicle
around and around and around
so you could see gravity really playing
on her and you could feel the reality of
it
and the reality was unfortunately very
uncomfortable for her
but the end result i think looks
fantastic actually
the the rig was like this giant humvee
uh kind of like a rotisserie chicken
that would like just
roll around and we would get
uh pretty much chained into it with all
these wires and
you have your like stunt uh costume all
your pads and things
and then they would like strap me in
almost like a
baby seat so i'd be like strapped from
behind strapped on the hips
and i couldn't move and i get incredibly
claustrophobic so like
immediately my heart starts pounding
super fast and i'm
about to have a panic attack and i'm
just like pull shoot already
because you know it takes forever to
like get ready and get everything ready
and
and then thing starts turning around and
they're throwing
all of this debris into the car and the
noise and the wind
and it's going round and round and round
and
i don't know how many takes we were able
to do before i completely
freaked out maybe three and i was like
okay i'm done i have to get out of this
i can't do
it anymore
normally when we would shoot like the
resident evil movies
um there would be a really tall guy in
like a skin-tight bodysuit
with like a really tall pole with like a
tennis ball connected to it and that
would be the monster but
in in monster hunter the monsters are so
much bigger than anything
we've ever shot ever in our history of
making movies together
that i would literally just look up at
the sky
because every time i would look up to
something like
you know paul would be like no higher
and so i would look up and they they put
the tennis ball higher and they'd be
like no
no higher higher and then at some point
the pole with the tennis ball just
couldn't get any higher so i just end up
like just looking straight up at the sky
paul made it easier too because he had
these really great um
rigs that would shoot like tons of sand
at the actors and it was it was really
intense so every time like the monster
would like put his foot down
or like run sand would like fly
everywhere but it would be
a real sand cannon i don't know how many
tons of sand alone
were being shot at us but it was just
like and all the sand would come so you
would be actually reacting
to things which you know makes it a lot
easier to imagine something is after you
that's like that huge
and whenever whenever the creature was
moving and you had to have like a
traveling eye line
um we'd try and put a drone up in the
air
so we'd have the drone at the correct
height of the monster
so like 40 feet high and so that if
there were two actors looking at the
same monster they would have a unified
eye line
and then we could uh we would use that
for establishing what the actors were
looking at
and then also those shots would kind of
double as a monster point of view or
over the shoulder shots
[Music]
i think when i first played the game i
was just blown away by these incredible
landscapes and these huge creatures the
the design of which i thought was very
very unique um
and that's really what i fell in love
with and in terms of bringing those
creatures to the screen i just tried to
be as true as possible to what was in
the video game
because i felt the design was was unique
enough i didn't need to add anything
i just needed to be truthful and uh
in in my quest to do that i worked
closely with the creators of the game to
make sure that i got
the fine detail of the creatures even
down to what their fingernails look like
as accurate as possible
it was pretty intense too because at
that point obviously i've got all of my
monster hunter
armor on and uh you know when you do
wire work
you have to have like a whole rig so you
have to have like
all of this padding and the whole suit
underneath the armor
and listen we were in the desert i mean
it was hot
and to like get into all of the stunt
gear
and all of the padding and then they had
to like
tie me into the armor and we don't have
any zippers or anything they're like
literally using you know leather cordage
to like tie me
into all of this stuff on top of the the
stunt
padding and yeah it was like it was
really cool because you know you have to
kind of do the motion of your arm
you know they counted down and it's like
okay three two one and then
bam and then you just fly up it was
really cool
i don't care what those creatures are
we destroy them and close the gateway
be sure to check out our film monster
hunter now
[Music]
foreign